gestern war ja der große zapfenstreich
aus meiner sicht endlich eine würdigung
der arbeit der soldatinnen soldaten im
einsatz in afghanistan
man muss ganz klar sagen der krieg in
afghanistan ist für den westen krachen
zu ende gegangen es ist krachend das
investment ist krachend gescheitert das
ist aber keine militärische niederlage
gewesen sondern in erster linie eine
politische niederlage und darüber müssen
wir uns auch in deutschland unterhalten
aus meiner sicht eine aufgabe des
nächsten deutschen bundestages sich mit
der frage zu beschäftigen was ist in
afghanistan schief gelaufen was und wo
waren die grossen fehler und vor allem
noch wichtiger welche lehren ziehen sie
aus dem afghanistan einsatz für die
zukunft für die zukunft in der
außenpolitik und vor allem mit blick auf
künftige auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr
wie beispielsweise derzeit in mali das
ist in der tat ein politisches versagen
und man konnte es ja wissen der als
donald trump angekündigt hat er werde
zurückziehen war völlig klar dass die
taliban zurückkehren ich bin 2002/2003
sehr früh in afghanistan gewesen und
über all die jahre ist es nie gelungen
die nester der taliban im süden
afghanistans
völlig auszutrocknen man hat sie zum
teil hinter die grenze nach pakistan
zurückgeworfen aber es war immer klar
sobald es ein machtvakuum gibt werden
sie da hin zurück stoßen und mit der
ankündigung trams hätte man eigentlich
beginnen müssen gegenstrategien zu
entwickeln das ist vor allem verheerend
für diejenigen die sich darauf verlassen
haben dass der besten dort eine stabile
ordnung bringt vielleicht hat das ja
sogar hervor gesagt vor zwei jahren
steigen muss ich auch deswegen und sie
haben das ja auch heiko maas dann damals
auch mitgeteilt ihre gedanken dass sie
glauben ich finde es wirklich ist es ist
es nicht nur ist es wirklich schon fast
erschreckend sie haben es ja vor gesagt
haben sie mitgeteilt kamen jetzt mal
irgend eine entschuldigung oder wurden
sie jetzt 1 6-pleite zu rate gezogen
weil sie es ja schon vor zwei jahren
darauf hingewiesen haben eine
entschuldigung kann man an der stelle
glaube ich auch nicht erwarten da kann
ich lange warten aber in der tat
ich habe mehrmals dieses thema
bereits schon vor zwei jahren auch im
auswärtigen ausschuss des deutschen
bundestages angesprochen und wir haben
das auch damals in der fraktionssitzung
2009/10 schon diskutiert und haben
gesagt wir brauchen jetzt dringend eine
exit strategie für afghanistan und es
völlig richtig es war aus meiner sicht
schon erkennbar wohin die reise gehen
wird als ich gesehen habe dass die
amerikaner fleißig mit den taliban
verhandeln und die afghanische regierung
gar nicht dabei ist natürlich eine
vorstellung davon was demnächst
passieren könnte das heißt spätestens ab
februar 2020 war klar dass die dass der
afghanistan einsatz für die amerikaner
and wird dass spätestens ab märz 20
20 hätte heiko maas sagen müssen oder
deutschland hätte sagen müssen das ist
unsere exit strategie und wir müssen so
schnell wie möglich gucken dass wir
sie dann ihre bedenken äußern werde es
ist ja nicht nur herr maas sondern wir
haben das ja auch gegenüber ist ja
meistens so auch vertreter auch das
verteidigungsministerium muss oder auch
andere auch staatsminister im
auswärtigen amt auch häufig im ausland
krank oder auch niels annen der auch als
staatsminister im auswärtigen ausschuss
war wir haben ja diese themen permanent
diskutiert aber weil häufig habe ich den
eindruck gehabt ja es gibt da eine us
strategie wir haben keine eigene
strategie für afghanistan sondern wir
folgen im wesentlichen die us strategie
und ja wenn wir dann irgendwann mal
sehen dass die dann weg gehen dann gehen
wir auch weg und ganz dramatisch warum
das noch zu erwähnen
der kappe kabul ist an einem samstag
gefallen und am freitagnachmittag haben
wir noch eine unterrichtung durch durch
das auswärtige amt bekommen vom
auswärtigen amt bekommen und die haben
uns freitag um 16 uhr noch gesagt kabul
wird nicht fallen wenn es dort zu einem
konflikt kommen dann wird das mehrere
monate dauern und wir haben das in dem
moment dann zur kenntnis genommen und am
nächsten tag sich auch die taliban sind
schon in kabul das heißt man kann
aussehen wie daneben wie schlecht die
deutsche politik informiert war mit
beiden beinen jenseits der realität
hätten ja nur dem bild lesen müssen paul
ronzheimer weisen diesen tagen nach nach
afghanistan gereist und
hat beschrieben wie die taliban auf
aufgabe verrückt aber meine frage stadt
zurück zuschauer meine frage an sie sie
befinden sich gerade in
koalitionsgesprächen mit spd und grüne
es sind noch vor sondierung und bringen
sich in form vor sondierungen die
absehbar auf absehbare auf tradition
verhandlungen hinauslaufen werden sie
haben also ich sagen räumen ein dass
deutschland offenbar zu sehr am mantel
zipfel der usa hängt die und wir müssen
auf eigenen beinen stehen und sie
sprechen auch maly an ist läuft offenbar
darauf hinaus dass europa sich bisschen
zusammenreißen müssen vielleicht
verantwortung in der welt hinaus das
würde bedeuten dass flecken panzer
auffahren müssen dass unsere drohnen
funktionieren müssen ist unsere
bundeswehr richtig ausgerüstet werden
jetzt befinden sich in
koalitionsverhandlungen mit parteien die
vollkommen andere prioritäten habe ich
viel spaß bei der forderung unserer
bundeswehr richtig aus zurück so
auszurüsten in verhandlungen mit den
grünen und der spd es bleibt er es
bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig denn
die welt in der wir leben verändert sich
gerade dramatisch und die amerikaner
interessieren sich immer weniger für den
nahen osten die interessieren sich
übrigens auch immer weniger für europa
die amerikaner sagen ganz klar wir
fokussieren uns auf china also die
auseinandersetzung zwischen china und
usa wird die politik dominieren in den
nächsten jahren die außenpolitik und die
sagen europa investiert doch selbst in
eure eigene sicherheit in eurer
diplomatie oder entwicklungshilfe werden
indem das sind da kommen da kommen wir
nicht drum herum wir haben in
afghanistan kann der eigene strategie
wir haben die strategie die amerikaner
in mali haben wir keine eigene strategie
wir verfolgen die strategie der
franzosen dass es ist doch höchste zeit
dass eine deutsche außenpolitik
erkennbar ist die dann aber auch einen
wichtigen beitrag zu einer
gesamteuropäischen außenpolitik antrag
aber die frage die frage da würde ich
auch gerne mal nachhaken wie der kollege
gerade gestellt hat mit welcher
forderungen geht ihr den reinen die
gespräche mit den grünen und mit der spd
also lasst sie fordert die fdp dann
etwas nicht wiederholen zunächst einmal
die dinge realistischer zu sehen also
jetzt konkret ist ja folgender gefragt
worden
wo wir künftig ein hebel ansetzen da
kommt glaube ich da kommt man nicht
vorbei mehr in die sicherheitspolitik zu
investieren selbstverständlich wird das
thema drohen eine rolle spielt übrigens
da sind die grünen gar nicht so weit von
uns entfernt die spd war bei dem thema
glaube ich in der letzten wahlperiode
ihm ginge er das auch und wem genau und
wie haben die die spd führt ja diese
debatte noch ich glaube wie es noch
nicht glauben militärtechnik ist nur das
eine das andere ist ein realistischer
blick auf die welt absoluten das
intervenieren in irgendwelche
krisenzonen das ist immer schnell
gemacht und dann die stabilisierung
hinterher ist in den meisten fällen
nicht zu schaffen wir haben ja überlegen
dass wir wie lange wir im kosovo stehen
das ist ein land vor unserer haustüre
eigentlich beitrittskandidat zur
europäischen union und auch dort gelingt
es nicht minderheiten auseinander zu
kriegen also etwas mehr realismus ist da
schon wäre da schon vonnöten und wenn
wir uns erinnern dass afghanistan eine
loja dschirga einberufen hatte noch
unter außenminister fischer als eine
stammesversammlung dann war eigentlich
von anfang an klar dass das
erstellen sozusagen einer zivilen orden
einer bürgerlichen gesellschaft die dann
die abwehrkräfte hat die taliban zurück
zu schlagen von anfang an eigentlich
ziemlich utopisch gewesen ist am
stabilsten basen noch als die vier
großen warlords das sagen hatten und aus
sagen wir mal so robust zeigen
mandatierung gegen die taliban
vorgegangen sind das ist nichts was wir
wirklich etablieren können wollen aber
der realistischen blick auf die welt
wäre schon ganz gut absolut dass
afghanistan eine demokratie wird ich
glaube das war von anfang an eine ganz
üble illusion einige haben dass er
tatsächlich geglaubt joschka fischer
stichwort aber
letztendlich wäre man doch froh gewesen
wenn man am ende zumindest strukturen
hätten die die sicherheit in der region
hätten tragen können und selbst das hat
nicht funktioniert wir haben wahnsinnig
viel investiert in die sogenannte
afghanische armee und die afghanische
polizei und wir wissen die sind in
wenigen stunden zusammengebrochen ohne
einen schuss abzugeben also dass dieser
diese diese niederlage ist dramatisch
und das darf deutschland oder das darf
die europäische union oder der nato auch
immer nicht passieren ich glaube in der
tat die welt realistischer zu sehen und
nicht immer durch die deutsche brille
oder durch die europäische brille dass
wir schon riesenschritt nach vorne
[Musik]